There appears to be a moderate genetic heritability for OCD, as seen from twin
studies, but researchers are still examining the biological basis of OCD. One
hypothesis has suggested heightened neural activity in the caudate nucleus. And
the anterior cingulate cortex, or ACC, of the brain. Some research findings
suggest that those with OCD have an overactive loop between the thought that
something is wrong, which the obsession, and wanting to do something about it
to make it stop, which is the compulsion. The obsession involves the ACC,
whereas the compulsion involves the caudate nucleus. This cycle goes on and on
and gets stuck leading to obsessive thoughts and compulsive behaviors. Now
let's go back to Lauren and talk about Post Traumatic Stress Disorder.